Wednesday uh Florida's Board of
Education approved what they're calling
standards for uh African-American
history I feel like they didn't talk to
any African-Americans cuz we could have
told them what bro what are you talking
about man about the history and nor have
any any you um you had you you seemingly
gone to the Smithsonian we're telling
you this history it's our American
history because you need to know so we
don't repeated and here you come to
santz trying to repeat what you first
off whoopy you got to lay off the pipe
I've heard from multiple sources you
show up to that show stoned every day I
don't know what the high hell you're
talking about the santis is not trying
to reinstitute SL Institute slavery or
teach anyone that slavery didn't exist
or anything like that but you flat out
lied when she said that they should have
talked to some black Scholars about this
uh but yes there are two Scholars who
are black they are African-American Dr
William B Allen and Dr Francis Presley
rice